24 year old right hander humberto mejia
out of panama he is 0-2 with a 7-20 era
he's in his second season in the big
leagues now one out and corey seeger the
batter final road game of the regular
season for the dodgers and seeger with a
fly ball to left center field well hit
and at the wall it is gone a home run
seeger goes the other way with his 11th
home run of the season and the dodgers
take a one to nothing lead
turner same spot he's got a home run
back to back
trey turner his third home run
in the last two days
25th of the year for turner it's two
nothing dodgers
instant offense in the top of the first
julio aureus on the mound for the
dodgers the 25-year-old left-hander 18-3
on this season with a 3-10 era carson
kelly coming up at 2 to 13 home runs
he's knocked in 43 hit a home run last
night off kershaw in the second half
two on two out the 2-2 pitch swung on
and missed right three on the change-up
and that'll end the inning
no runs one hit two left after one
dodgers two arizona nothing
now seeger did a home run the other way
into the first row
two two
sega hits this one high
his second of the game it's three
nothing dodgers
oh is he hot now an even dozen home runs
on the season
it's the 100th home run of siegel's
career and the badger is muncie here it
is and he got him swinging got him on a
breaking ball
and muncie down on strikes first strike
out of the afternoon
outs of the inning foreign on and two
out and looks at the plate
he is over one with a pop to third
here's the 01 pitch deluxe and a ground
ball to first fielded by walker he'll
take it to the bag and the side is
retired
so caleb smith couple of pitches gets
the final out dodgers get a run david
peralta coming up
peralta an infield hit in his first stat
bat
one ball two strikes bases loaded bottom
of the third dodgers three nothing and
for urias's 57th pitch swung onto this
strike three fastball elevated so urias
comes back and shuts down the
diamondbacks who leave the bases loaded
after three it's the dodgers three in
arizona nothing christian walker 0 for
one and a walk two balls two strikes two
out walker strikes out swinging and that
will end the unit hurry us his third
strikeout of the game
retires the d-backs in order and through
five it's the dodgers three arizona
nothing now taylor the hitter
wayne gonna miss he went down with that
heavy sinker at 95
and taylor strikes out for the second
time today and now here's barnes now the
2-2 and he got him swinging he came back
with that slider and got
barnes out on strikes two outs
pulls pitch hit last night in the
seventh inning and he's announced here
he pitch hit against man applied hit
into a double play
two men out man applied to the plate
and he got him swinging so manipulate
strikes out pulls
and that ends the inning so after the
back-to-back hits three consecutive
strikeouts too by popping
up by man apply pulls down on strike
sending over
cole calhoun is going to come up and
pinch it
calhoun of course a left-handed hitter
and now calhoun one and two
finds it into short right but turner
with a shift on makes the play and the
inning is over
that was a case where the shift
absolutely paid off
no runs one hit two left
as we go to the seventh
dodgers three arizona nothing seeger now
who was over twice and popped a short
over to left field and he pulled one to
right two home runs give him 12 in the
year now and 50 rbis
he and turner went back to back on
consecutive pitches
from mejia in the first inning here's
the one to the next one seeger strikes
out swinging he chased one up and out
over the plate and clippers retired the
first two in the dodgers seventh and now
turner
ground ball down to third vargas has got
it he's got to be quick and they just do
get turner at first base two in the
inning here's marshall now is one for
three of the ball game dodgers have
seven hits today d-backs have six
the big number up there on the board is
nine
that's nine runners left on base for
arizona
so they've had chances well the big deal
in the western division the giants and
they have just beaten the rockies six to
two
ground ball to second base var show
easily thrown out an easy inning again
for joe kelly
now runs oh hits though airs nobody left
will go to the eighth dodgers three
arizona nothing
and now chris taylor the header
taylor has walked in the ball game and
struck out twice got the start started
third today over justin turner
runners lead muncien pollock
3-2 pitch and a fly ball hit it pretty
well to right center
back on it goes far show and makes a
catch no brahmos made the catch throat
comes back in it was ramos who caught it
with marshall running by him for the
second out of the inning
wow
well very fortunate for the diamondbacks
obviously miscommunication out there and
now two outs for the dodger catcher
austin barnes
fly ball to left center that's trouble
can anybody get there peralta
and who caught it
it was martial who caught that one with
peralta running by him down the other my
goodness
well they caught him they made it
interesting the dodgers failed to score
they leave a pair
two out and david peralta coming up
peralta is one for three
two two
five ball to right bets going back he'll
make the catch a step in front of the
warning track
walter flies to right the inning is over
no runs no hits though there's nobody
left will go to the ninth dodgers
looking to pick up an insurance runner
two leading at three to nothing
and when dalkin is on turner who came in
the game
last half inning to play third base will
lead it off he's in the pitcher's spot
justin turner
caleb smith shawn poppin joe mantiply
tyler clifford taylor wider now jb
wendell can perdomo the rookie at
shortstop he's a good one
21 years old geraldo perdomo
someone out down here spencer's over
four today punches need a win to remain
two back with six to play
bets deep to center
the show's at the wall he's got it
dalton varsio takes one away tip of the
cap
as much he'll settle in here and brings
home the old one and there's a fly ball
to left
back on it goes peralta in front of the
wall out there he's got it
and the sides retired
dodgers one out away from their 100th
win of the year
cattell martay all for four this
afternoon
[Applause]
hit on the ground right to muncie and
this will do it
win number 100 for the dodgers